I'm gonna miss just being on set I'm
gonna miss being with those great people
the crew and the team and Peter and the
other actors they remember remember
everything that happened
Ian McKellen as Gandalf the Grey and
Richard Armitage is Thorin and Martin
Freeman has Bilbo Baggins that office
I'm gonna of course miss my ears in my
hair they're amazing
but I think the thing that I would like
to be able to do at least once a month
is walk onto a Pierre Jackson set and
have a fully realized middle-earth that
experience was like being a kid in a
candy shop
I enjoyed making the Hobbit more than I
ever thought I was it was 18 months of
shooting but I'm gonna miss the fact
I'll never get to do that again you have
peace o war
I'm a little sad to say goodbye to
middle-earth at this point it actually
felt like we were the air felt like we
were in this extraordinary mythic place
in the IMAX experience you can see far
and wide the IMAX screen is so immersive
that you feel that you are actually in
some of those scenes which is exactly
what we wanted
I can't imagine middle-earth being
depicted any other way what do you
follow me one last time
you